normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
the SF Chronicle David deap describes
far-right conspiracies that led him to
Pelosi house that's right this is the
guy who attacked Paul Pelosi and he
testified the other day these stories
went wild he was claiming that he wanted
to get Nancy Pelosi to confess on camera
while he wore a unicorn costume and then
he wanted Biden to Pardon her for these
crimes which is a just a all all around
the dude's clearly unwell but uh who do
you think they're blaming for for all of
this in all of these new comment
sections and on leftist Twitter and all
these chats I that sounds like something
Ian would say the the the the unicorn
unicorn costume and then get the
president to to and and uh uh I you know
I want to say that um this is a guy who
wanted Joe Biden to Pardon Nancy Pelosi
let me read the story they say David de
the man accused of attacking Paul Pelosi
with a hammer in San Francisco last year
testified in his federal trial Tuesday
offering the most detailed Glimpse to
date into the motivations and
conspiracies that drove him to embark on
what he said he and his lawyers
described as a mission to fix a world
corrupted by democrats under questioning
from his own attorney toap sketched the
Contours of his worldview and his
political leanings both of which were
heavily informed by conservative media
personnels and podcasters David deap
testified that he subscribed to a number
of baseless and wildly discredited
conspiracy theories many of which
revolved around assert of cabals of high
ranking public officials and celebrities
harming children
uh yada yada he says he used to be
leftwing and I wonder if the chronicle
actually removed the references but uh
sech yeah did it I think they might have
taken it out maybe they were scared that
we were going to sue him uh did I get
did I make the cut okay here we go I'm
Sor I'm sorry I'm sorry here here it is
we're here we're here he turned instead
to conservative commentators Tim p and
James Lindsay the said he also went on
to mention many others he mentioned
glenbeck and other channels but I just
want to shout out uh depending on which
news Outlet you read they'll choose
selectively which person he claimed to
have been listening to and uh Tim p and
James Lindsay and I am offended by this
because as Phil pointed out the
demanding Joe Biden pardon the Democrats
for that's all Ian Ian what are you
doing you getting me in trouble over
here as soon as I as soon as I heard
this I was like he didn't pay attention
to anything Tim said that's all Ian
Crossland famous far right commenter Ian
cross same thing happened to me though
they gave one of my quotes to Ian they
get all of his quotes screwed up yeah
who was it Media Matters who claimed
that your quote was Ian it was I think
it was Gawker and I was talking about
how horribly destructive no fault
divorce is and they said Ian crossin
said it like that's that's not that was
like clearly something I would say and
they're like Ian crossin said but they
don't watch the show enough right they
don't know who any of you guys are so so
this is a guy who committed a horrible
attack you know on Paul Pelosi these
things shouldn't happen they need better
security and uh they're claiming oh he
was watching you know my show whatever
and and I saw this story I thought it
was funny Media Matters quoted me the
last time when the guy in Texas posted
four clips from IRL and the quote is Tim
pool says I think it's funny and I just
don't care or something like that and
I'm like yeah dude look there will not
be a single person who can ever ever get
me to care that some dude W some dude
who did some bad thing watched my show
we get millions upon Millions that's
insane the idea that James F first of
all I want to shout out conservative
commentator James Lindsay I mean which
is laughable up Jim sup Jim yeah and uh
but I but one thing I really love about
Ian crosson who's not here unfortunately
tonight um the thing that's great about
him is he's he's a weird guy he doesn't
fit in any political box his opinions
are wild he's for the death penalty he's
like very much for it we had this big
conversation where he was like what we
got to get you know got to have the
death penalty for these people and I'm
like whoa but then he's like but we got
to Pardon all Hillary Clinton and I'm
just like he's kind of wild but the he
helps break the machine because when
Gawker takes a quote from Sheamus and
applies it to Ian or when Hassan perer
claims Ian is a conservative it shows
you that they're they're they're complet
their arguments are meaningless
completely empty I I don't think we
should take this at face value Julie of
course has been following the January 6
trials and you know Julie that there are
many cases where at the coaching of
attorneys the the guy who had one motive
is coached into a different storyline
that is made palatable for the media
palatable for the jury palatable for the
judge to show compassion so what I see
here is a leftist who has now realized
that uh moving right and claiming to be
under the right-wing spell will suddenly
get him a lot of sympathetic attention
uh sentencing lower sentencing uh yeah
the conservatives drove him crazy well
and this guy is an illegal immigrant
from Canada who voted for the green
party I mean mean this is why they had
to construct The Narrative and that's
why they needed a migration because they
know he started left so they had to
account for that it probably still is it
probably still is this proves it it's
just one big conspiracy against me I'm
the victim here you are the center of
the universe I'm the victim CU last
paragraph there talking about Gail Rubin
at the very end it says uh talking about
particularly on pedophilia and sexual
relationships have been misconstrued
nothing that Gail ruin that that that
James Lindsay has said about Gail
rubin's writings none of it has been
misconstrued it is all word for word
stuff that she has written in her books
and let me drive it home I don't I don't
know about where this guy gets his ideas
or or anything like that I will say it's
certainly a Tim pool idea to Pardon
corrupt politicians but they bring up
Gail Rubin in this why she has nothing
to do with the pelis the this man going
to to the Pelosi's house and wanting to
attack or harm Pelosi has nothing to do
with James Lindsay or Gail Rubin it does
seem like what you said Desh that hey
look I bet his defense attorneys said
here's what you're going to do you're in
San Francisco this is the jury you got
to claim it's the right-wing that
radicalized you attack James Lindsay
Glenn backck Tim p and there's a few
others they mentioned and uh then you'll
get lesser charges they'll use that to
weave a narrative I mean Julie hasn't
this exactly been the January 6th not in
some cases the where the courta
appointed attorneys have lured the
defendants into this kind of whole
therapeutic I used to be a trumpster
I've now realized that he deceived me
that's what Jenna Ellis said right if I
had known what when she said that she
was going to plead guilty in Georgia she
said if I had known what I know now I
would never have acted that way I mean
it's like renounce everything you've
ever done and throw yourself on the
mercy of these completely biased juries
we're having conversation right now they
had they've had they do have struggle
sessions still ongoing and you had a
public defender um Heather Shaner who's
represented several January 6 defendants
and she actually gives them a list of
books and movies to read to forgive
themselves for their white privilege and
then they will go to the judge and
they'll write an apology letter or they
will apolog you know tell the judge in a
letter or verbally you know I didn't
realize how racist and uh anti-semitic
and we killed all the Native Americans
and uh so these are the F
defend my own campaign Finance case
think about this I give money to Wendy
long who's running college friend of
mine and the judge this is the part I
want to focus on as part of my sentence
psychiatric counseling as if my behavior
is so inexplicable it
demands psychiatric therapy but see I
think what they were getting at is had I
gone through the psychological
counseling 8 months and I had come out
and sort of seen the light
and I realize I'm actually now a leftist
and I'm now applying for like a job on
MSNBC I would have been declared cured
can I wouldn't that be hilarious if you
actually did that just to troll the
system if you're like no yeah I'm a
leftist and got a job on MSNBC and then
their highest rated host was someone who
is re-educated into being a leftist
here's here's a point that I want to
make about this case that I think
everyone needs to ask themselves as Desh
pointed out and and as mentioned uh
Julie Kelly in your work January Sixers
are given this narrative why would a
criminal defendant go on the stand for
several hours and explain that the crime
he committed was actually part of a much
much larger conspiracy and that he
actually was attempting several more
crimes for what purpose would the CL
would this defendant be advantaged by
admitting to further criminal conspiracy
on the
stand I mean he's obviously
theoretically going to help the state
with something there's no way that
counsel to do that unless they
potentially could throw someone there's
no legitimate legal circumstance where
they're like go up there and admit to
doing more crimes admit to having
wanting to do more crimes unless the
narrative was how can we rope in
rightwing conspiracy stuff so you have a
guy who attacked Paul Pelosi and that's
the story he was a leftist he was a
green party guy he was Canadian they
want to weave this into a story about
the far right but how do you he attacked
Paul Pelosi well of course the Pelosi
are there so then he has to go on and
say well Nome and Gail Rubin were
targets too so you're admitting to
wanting to do more crimes to create the
narrative that's right yeah my guess is
this guy is out of his mind and they
realize that they could now move him
like a puppet in whatever Direction they
they wanted to and so they've
constructed a narrative I I I think it
might be simple enough that his defense
came to him and said look you're in San
Francisco it is as blue as blue can be
you attacked the leader of the
democratic party's husband you need to
shift this politically and this is a
scary thing for what's happening in this
country well keep in mind too excuse me
uh Tim but the US capital police the
same organization that allowed the
capital to be left unsecured on January
6th they were monitoring the Pelosi
property in real time so they've
expanded their offices out of Washington
they shouldn't to parts of Florida and
California so they were monitoring and
they said oh we just looked away and
whatever then all of a sudden this guy
bursts into the house breaks into the
house so it's also part of to your to
your point you're right but also
covering up again another agency that
really should be disbanded Congress
shouldn't have their own police force
not only are they protecting that not
protecting in this case uh but they're
totally incompetent should be disbanded
and they're they're once again trying to
cover up what they did wrong we had a
legal issue uh year or so ago so I call
my lawyer and I say hey we've got we've
got this legal dispute civil not
criminal and a civil tort of some sort
and he said uh okay well if we Sue in uh
uh in California we lose instantly if we
Sue in New York we lose instantly
instantly because the these were big uh
media corporations that we were looking
at and he goes so obviously we're going
to try and do it in West Virginia which
means we need to figure out why we have
standing to be in West Virginia to do it
and I laughed and I was like I totally
get it and he goes you look man you get
a judge in New York and they're going to
be corporate and they're going to be
Democrats and they instantly hate you no
matter what you say because you're Tim
pool you go to West Virginia and they're
probably going to instantly like you I
got to be honest you file in West
Virginia the judge is going to side with
you no matter what you say and I'm like
that's crazy but that's the reality of
where we are with this political
bifurcation absolutely outside of any
Grand conspiracy or narrative crafting
or whatever we want to say may have
happened I think his defense lawyers
just said look man pretend that tell
everyone that it's the evil Boogeyman
far right that made you do it and cross
your fingers well you know you mentioned
earlier Jenna Ellis and um and part of
what's going on here is that the plea
bargain system has become a legal
bludgeon um in which they come to you
and in effect say we can get something
on you no matter what and and now what
they do is they because of the large
Federal accordion of statutes they can
redescribe the same thing you did and
have multiple charges in my campaign
Finance case they were like we'll get
you on bank fraud because you took your
money out of the bank we'll get you on
mail fraud because you put your check in
the mail and see those things carry
years in prison and so then they go okay
but if you sign here and plead to this
and so whether you're guilty or innocent
makes no difference if you make a
rational calculation you have to take
the plea but of course politically it's
ruinous because then everybody jumps up
and goes see he admitted it he so let me
let me let me give you an example I was
at a criminal trial a long time ago this
is another lifetime and the the federal
prosecutors said of the defendant who
quite literally broke no law but they
were trying to put in prison for decades
I was flabbergasted when I heard the
prosecutor say they were it was
sentencing hearing why they wanted to
justify very very long prison sentence
and the prosecutor said your honor the
defendant used a uniform resource
locator through the hypertext transfer
protocol to obtain private information
of people he did not have the right to
get information from and I was like oh
my God he just said the dude typed in a
a URL into a web browser but he said it
in such a way so that the jury and the
judge would be like wow what is this
crazy technical thing for which I am uh
not understanding if I said you're honor
the dude typed some words into the
browser bar and pressed enter and they
sent him information he'd be like well I
do that every day right but they're
trying to justify putting him in prison
for a decade plus so that's why they use
that language I mean uh after this being
a police state film people come up to me
and they're like well you know Dena I'm
not Donald Trump and I didn't go in the
capital on January 6th and I pay my
taxes and you know I'm okay they're not
going to come after me and I say to
these guys I go listen why don't you
tell me for 10 minutes about your life
what do you do tell me where you live
tell me how you get to work you know
you're a doctor and I say after you
after 10 minutes I will tell you three
felonies that you can be charged with
that you will be defenseless against so
for example you're a doctor okay I'm
going to charge you with illegal
administration of pain medication I will
find one client that you administered a
pain drug to who says I didn't need it
right and I will then bring in an expert
witness a doctor who will testify she
really didn't need it you'll be facing
years in prison you'll be facing not
being able to be a doctor ever again or
you take a plea bargain you pay a
$100,000 fine you don't practice for a
year and then you can get back into it
well who wouldn't take that deal you
know that they got you it's blackmail
and it's it's blackmail and you're being
framed well it's called It's called The
Jury taxy and it's some people call the
trial tax or the jury tax and the
argument they make is well you see when
you plead guilty you're you're accepting
responsibility which shows some remorse
and some change already therefore you'll
get a lesser sentence for that the
reality is the emergence of this is
mostly due to the fact the state cannot
handle the amount of cases laid before
it if every person in this country who
was criminally charged demanded a jury
trial the system would would collapse
overnight well I just want to mention
because we spoke to him on the show
probably about two years ago but Brandon
straa had a very similar situation he
did not go in the capital he was just
out on the steps they claimed that they
heard his voice in the footage that he
filmed saying something that wasn't even
necessarily incendiary even in of itself
and they were threatening him with
something like 19 years in prison and so
they got him to plea down basically this
is what I remember about covering the
proud boys trial right they were all
charged with conspiracy but also if you
look back in the documents Dominic Piza
who had thrown some or there a video of
him like taking glass out of a window he
if he like broke it yeah um the he got
moved onto the caseway later they moved
people around based on who they could
offer please to create this idea that
there was a
uniform that's what was so amazing about
the Whitmer Federal criminal trial and I
know you guys had Brandon certa on and
um the fact that you had and the thing
with plea deals too is they are
considered convictions by the Department
of Justice there's not a category that's
like and this is true I just up only
like 80% of federal criminal cases
charges end up are are pleaded out but
they're still listed as a conviction so
what was so amazing with the Whitmer
fedna trial is that you had two of the
six Federal defendants who pleaded
guilty and then they became government
Witnesses but then you had four
defendants who took the risk they went
to trial in a jurisdiction really a jury
of their peers which they had and you
had two men Daniel Harrison and certa
who were here who were acquitted
outright on every single charge and then
the other two men who had a hung jury
and of course then the doj went back but
that's why it's so am that case in it in
and of itself is just amazing thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at
timcast.net
time